Welcome back, I'm
Ellen Drew.
Today we'll
talk about the exact copywriting routine I follow to improve my copywriting skills and stay sharp every day
.  In fact,
many of you have read the book '
Atomic
Habits'
.  In that
book,
he says that if you improve 1% every day, you will improve 365% in a year.
I
strongly
believe in it,
if not I
will double it.  I
improve by 2% every day.
So, even if you do
half of what I do, you can
achieve very, very good results.
But if
you want
to see exactly what I do every day, let's get
started without further ado.
God
bless you.
That's
great.
Awesome.  Okay.
To explain, to be
honest
, my
copywriting
routine is pretty
simple
.  This is
nothing strange
.  Now it doesn't have to be
much
effort
.  That means it was
hard at first
, but
you need concentration,
discipline,
and taking it
seriously
.
If you don't want
to work hard
, you'd
better go to another video, okay?
We
work hard here, we
work, and that's how
we
grow.
If not,
see you in the next video.  Speaking of my
copywriting
routine
,
it's divided into four
parts
.  Okay?  They are
writing,
studying, reading,
and
thinking (
incubating
).  Okay, these are
four
different
levels, and it
takes me about 2 hours a day.  It's
not that big of a time.
Some people have 2
hours
,
some do
n't.  I have a
wife,
three
children, a
career,
exercise, and
volunteer
services at church, so many
things to do,
right?  If you
take it seriously, you can
dedicate 2 hours a day
.  If it
doesn't work, it's
no big deal.  Okay,
approximately 30
minutes
are allotted for each part
.  The first is writing
.  I dedicate the first 30 minutes of my copywriting
routine to
writing
.
It could be 500 words
, or it could be
1,000 words
.    To be
honest
, I'm not going to
lie
, I
probably write for more
than 30 minutes
.
Many times
I get in the flow and
write for an hour or an hour and a half,
when I have time.
But I promise myself that I will
write for at least 30 minutes
.
Surely there will be
days when I only work for 30 minutes
, right?
Some days
I don't feel like working
.  When I'm
not on the farm, I stop
working after 30 minutes
.
But as long as I finish my 30
minutes
,
I'll be satisfied
.
So you
complete your 30 minutes.
It could be writing an email
.
That could be writing a sales
page copy
,
right?  If you're learning a
sales page
, is it okay to handwrite it
or type it
?  It could be
writing.
It could be writing a video
sales letter
,
your own
sales letter
,
writing Facebook ads, Google headlines,
writing tweets, threads, Medium articles,
right?  Whatever you're
writing copy for,
just write for 30
minutes
, okay?
You can do free writing without any
goal
.  Write what's on your
mind
.  You can
also
write about any imaginary product.  You can
go online and search for a product you
like
.
For example, I
like guitars and books.
I like guitar
pedals
.  I can
write about a guitar pedal I found online and
write a sales letter to them even if they don't hire me.
You can
write for your clients.
Finish writing in just 30 minutes
.  The second part of my copywriting
framework is
about the next 25-35 minutes.
I took this
from Gary Bensenga, one of the most productive and profitable copywriters
.    If
you have
n't heard of Gary Benzenga,
look him up on Google,
because he's a
really
amazing
guy.  He has generated
over $1 billion in
sales in direct response advertising
.
His tip to improve 1% every day, to stay sharp, and to stay at the top is
to read an ad every day.  You've probably heard the saying, "An
apple a day keeps the
doctor away
."  Also, if you
read an ad every day, you
will become a good and profitable copywriter.
For that I use a website called 'swiped.co'
.
Okay,
here is the link.
You can go to swipe.co and
type in anything in the niche you want,
it could be about that copywriter
.
For example, if you
go to swipe.co and
type in Gary Benzenga, you
can see some of the ads he wrote.
Most of the time
I
go to swipe.co and print them out
, because I
prefer physical copies
.
I
like to see and read them.  I will
print this out,
look at it, and study
that
sales
letter
thoroughly with a pen in hand
.  So,
this is the
study part of my framework.  Oh,
look at the word he used.  Wow,
he
used urgency here.  Look at
how specific that part
is.
I really
liked the way he put the deadline there.
Evidence,
evidence,
evidence.  I study the sales letter to see what I'm
doing,
what the experts are
and I do this for
about 30
minutes
, right
?  You may not be
able to complete the entire sales letter
.  You may not be able to complete the entire
statement
.  I do this many times when I read Ben
Settle and
Daniel
Thrass'
emails
.  I
study their emails
.
Anyway,
this is a very
intentional
piece to help you pay more attention to what you read.  It makes
you
sharper
and it
really sinks into your
bones
.    As
Gary
Halbert
says
, it sinks into your
bones
and you
feel it the next time you write
.  This
leads me to the next 30 minutes,
which is
reading about copywriting.
Okay.  So
this is
not the part that is studied.
There is a difference between the two.  Studying copywriting is something
I try very
hard to do
.  This is
very
different from this stage,
where I
take a book that I think is well written.
Sometimes
it might be a book that teaches me more about copywriting
.
Sometimes
it might be a novel that has
nothing to do with copywriting
,
but it's a
great
storyline,
because
story is
so crucial in copywriting.
And
sometimes
it could be
more
sales
letters or
emails that I like,
or a course I'm
taking
, something like that
.
But it's just a matter of
reading for pleasure
and absorbing that
knowledge
.
And I
do this for about 30 minutes.
Again,
before going to bed at night,
I might read for another 15-20
minutes
.  Okay.
And the last part of my
copywriting
routine is something that
many people
overlook.
Incubation.
Okay.  As Joe
Sugarman says in his
Copywriter's
Handbook
, incubation is the
time you spend away from copywriting after you've done some serious studying or writing.  Okay,
so let's say I
just spent 30, 40
minutes
writing a sales letter and studying a sales
letter
.  Okay, I have
a lot of thoughts running through my head
.  I'm trying to understand some
things
.  Many times
I get up from my desk and
go for a walk for about 30 minutes,
where I
just
think.
I just
enjoy walking
or playing something like tennis to stimulate my
brain
.
Okay, let's think things through
.  What this
does is that
your
subconscious mind begins to
make connections between whatever you are intensely focusing on
.  Yes?  And as
it starts to build relationships
, you start to have more '
aha' moments
.  Those
'aha' moments can
be headline and sub-headline bullet points you never expected.  Yes?
It might be an
idea you saw while studying the product
, but
you didn't pay much attention to it at the time
, and
now it's taking shape in your
brain
.  So
'
incubation
' (letting ideas
mature
) is a
crucial part of copywriting.    I'll
say it again,
every great guy I know,
Gary Benga,
Gary Halper,
John
Carlton,
Clayton
Makepeace, all of
them, Jim
Rutts, they all
focus on this incubation as part of their process.  Yes,
that's
a
professional
part of the copywriting journey.  So don't skip that
step at all
.
Looking back at the daily 2-hour routine, that includes
about
30 minutes of writing
.  Again,
it could be 500 words
, it
could be 1,000 words,
it
doesn't matter.  About 30
minutes
writing, 30
studying,
okay?  Taking a
sales letter,
an ad, anything, and
studying it very intensively,
reading it for about 30 minutes.  Yes?
Fill your mind with good copy, good thoughts, and healthy ideas.  You do
n't have to scroll through social media for 30 minutes.
You should read for 30
minutes
.  Finally,
incubation
.  Make sure those things are organized in your
mind and
connected to each other
so that you can
write the best copy possible.  And, to
wrap this up,
if you
can't do 2 hours a day,
maybe start with an hour a day
, okay?  15
minutes, 15
minutes
and 15
minutes.  Okay, 15
minutes of writing, 15
minutes of
studying, 15
minutes of reading,
and 15
minutes of
incubation
.  You can start very
small
.  It took
me a few
years to get here
,
so
I can't
say that beginners can do it right away.
However, I aim to be
in that top 1%
, which is why I
take my work very seriously
and I will become
one of the highest paid copywriters in the world
.
So if you want
to do the same,
you should
do the same by following what I am building.
And before
we end today
,
I
will provide some materials for you to study for free.
You can click on the link in the description below to
get the Copywriting Catalyst,
which gives you 63 profitable copywriting tips that I've read and collected over the past
few
years for
free
.
You can take this and
read and practice a lesson every day,
which is a great
way to develop your copywriting skills.
Thank you again for watching.
I hope you like it
.  If you found this video
useful, please
hit the like and subscribe button, I'll
see you in the next video.  Okay,
some bonus
tips if you like to read good books.
Cash
Advertising
, Ogilvy on
, Breakthrough
Advertising
.  Wow, that's an
amazing
book.  You will
really
enjoy it.